tiene todos los ingredientes de un
cuento de hadas una princesa antepone el
amor y se casa con un plebeyo pero la
noticia no ha conquistado a todos los
japoneses medianos creo que la cobertura
mediática de esta historia fue exagerada
y lo siento por ella en ese sentido pero
por otro lado ella tenía un estatus
simbólico era un pilar de nuestro país
estoy muy en desacuerdo con los que
están en contra de este matrimonio lo
más importante es que ya sea feliz
la princesa maco anunció su compromiso
con keiko muro su novio de la
universidad en septiembre de 2017 y los
problemas comenzaron en tres meses
después cuando la prensa japonesa reveló
una disputa financiera entre la madre
del joven y su ex marido en juego está
una deuda de unos treinta mil euros
suficiente para que algunos se
preguntarán por los motivos del
pretendiente de la princesa maco
especialmente en japón donde la familia
imperial está sujeta a exigentes
estándares de pureza la tormenta
mediática empujó a la familia a posponer
la boda y en 2018 como volvió a eeuu
para terminar sus estudios de derecho la
pareja estuvo separada durante más de
tres años finalmente se han casado
aunque en privado y sin la pompa y la
ceremonia habituales
[Música]
para mí que es insustituible cuando los
rumores unilaterales se convirtieron en
historias infundadas me asusto me
molestó y me dolió
conexión bajo astori más quiero a maco
solo tenemos una vida y quiero pasarla
con la persona que ama estos temas la
princesa ha dejado el palacio real para
empezar una nueva vida en estados unidos
pero casarse con ccoo muro ha supuesto
un coste para ella ya que ha renunciado
al millón de euros de dote que le
correspondía así como a su título real
una regla que sólo aplica a las mujeres